以前有個吸毒仔
他媽跟他說
我覺得你這樣吸毒不好
你要不要認真學點
不然你學點做交易好了
他就認真去學當沖
當沖到一半之後他媽又跟他講
不然你回去吸好了
歡迎收看財經超能力
我是慶祥
各位觀眾朋友注意到嗎
在2024年年底的時候
立院就通過了一個
你為了你是投資人還蠻重要的一個法案
就是在2025年開始
要延长三年的当充证交税
也就是说一般的交易的证交税
大概是千分之三
但是当充的证交税
则是千分之1.5
所以让很多当充客
真的是很喜欢做当充电的事情
但是如果你真的是用时间
每天都在盯着盘的时候
做当充真的是可以让你
一天赚了好几十万都说不定
到底要怎么当充呢
其实盘前盘中跟盘后
都有很多事情要做
今天就來一起來了解一下
我們台灣最大的當沖客
可以這樣講嗎 全聖小哥
沒有到最大的當沖客
就是你在檯面上有
你在 你看得到的
我大概算 量算很大
是不是最大我不確定
至少前三名
前三名的
但是檯面下有很多做得比我大
台面下 他們沒有出來而已
這時候下面就會有人說
為什麼你還要出來
為什麼要出來
不然人生就只有當沖不是很無聊
我也要出來外面
透透氣
透透氣 交交朋友
郭文聰沒有錯
今天我們錄影的時間是下午
因為他說他早上都要交易
對啊 因為我早上
誰給你早上來錄影
其實當沖還滿多優點跟缺點
真的很迷人是不是
我早上來國家稅說少20萬
你說如果早上
那我今天真的是對得起國家
約你下午來
沒錯
我說任何月我早上來
你說那你要拿20萬交易稅捐給國家
所以你每一天的證交稅就20萬
大概20萬
平均
平均20萬
因為一年的交易稅算起來
大概四五千萬
那一年算200多個交易日
所以大概就一天大概20萬
所以我們先講一下
為什麼當沖對你來說這麼迷人它也是有些優點的對不對當沖就是當天就結算了所以就是那種反應那種回饋很直接
那種多巴胺非常多
但通常你會選擇什麼樣的個股
或者是你會用什麼樣的條件
來做你當沖的選擇
其實當沖
這個我們講了很多
可是很多人當沖都憑感覺
所以第一個你當沖憑感覺
不要充了啦
你充不赢啦
我们是专业的
我们不是凭感觉
我们是靠城市算筹码
算年内次 年内量
年外次 年外量
那我们还可以
不只算筹码
我们还可以去看筹码
看当下筹码
因为这个证交所他还有公布
购买中心那边有公布
所以当初我们有很多东西可以看
所以当你不知道要去看这些东西
一直凭感觉下单的时候
你们家有金山银山都输不完的
都输不完的
对啊你有没有听过一个笑话
什么
所以以前有个吸毒仔
那个他妈跟他说
我觉得你这样吸毒不好
你要不要认真学点
不然你学点做交易好了
那他就认真去学当充
当充到一半之后他妈又跟他讲
不然你回去吸好了
哈哈哈
賠光了
賠更多你知道嗎
賠比吸的還得更多
所以意思就是說什麼意思
不要這個
沒學當沖不要來碰啦
不要來碰因為
你沒有研讀籌碼你不要來碰當沖啦
不要來碰當沖因為這個
這個你
你沒學籌碼老是憑感覺
就快要漲了進去買
快要跌進去賣
那個都沒有用
而且台灣大部分人做當中
都是先買再賣
但是據統計
做量化交易統計裡面
做先賣再買的勝率是比較高的
所以一般人做當中
一開始就做錯
他們都是做先買再賣
先買再賣可不可以當中
當然可以
先買再賣是適合誰做
適合資金很多的人做
像你一樣
我可是我也不喜歡做切板菜賣
因為切板菜賣有一個問題就是
你買了也不曉得誰要把你賣下來可能就比較麻煩了所以我們講一下當沖的優點一 槓桿開很大利用市場剝削獲利
第二個 計算籌碼勝率頗高
第三 快速獲取利潤避免隔夜的風險
所以就是一天 今日是今日比
第四 可控風險
運用出價單可以控制當天虧損的最大值
什麼叫出價單
出價單就是價格到了他要幫你送
嗯
所以你會有一個目標
對 例如說
那個
你50塊買了
嗯
我說50塊買了你就要開始放出價單
你要多少錢停損啊
嗯
你可以50塊買了嘛
那你就48.9停損
哦
就跌破49塊幫我停損
他就自動幫你買
對 跌到48.9他就自動幫你出掉
就這樣 這叫出價單啊
嗯
那這個
第五個 現貨當沖交易稅減半
第六 萬一下抽單可以馬上停損
所以當沖的這些優點
可以降低虧損部位的成本
例如說空單虧損流倉盤中急殺
我們就先買
所以你會做當沖
它其實可以幫助你做一些
部位的一些調控
那它還有一些缺點吧
不然吸毒仔他怎麼會
想要回去吸毒呢
我先講當沖缺點一
第一個不能流倉即便也是對的
有些人他多單
他沒有辦法流倉
結果漲停他沒辦法流
所以他就是all in了
所以他必須要除掉
是這個意思
漲停沒辦法流很可惜
因為通常漲停隔天容易開高
所以我們都說當沖
玩當沖的人你要有一筆周轉金
要有多少錢
越多越好
對 越多越好
那你資金少了沒關係
你就玩比較小的
那最好就是
最好是你今天這個
你下單量
通常我們都建議說
你可能一天下五檔
那每天至少要有一檔
你可以流倉的
對 流倉的資金
大概是五分之一
好 這樣子
好 第二呢
做多低淺縮食沒錢交割
這更慘
這有可能會
這好像
違約交割
對 已經違約了
對啊 那個做多漲停的
很多人都想說賣掉就好了但是賣掉也不對因為還有可能隔天會開高嗎對那做多跌停的哦這個這個你講沒錢交割就為了交割是哦
所以這個
這種你可能要去
辦個踢加五啦
好好
那第三呢
做工漲停鎖死沒錢交割哇
這是最慘
好
好因為
漲停鎖死沒錢交割又沒券的話
哇那他要收那個借券費啊
是哦
這種借券費非常的昂貴
好 第五個
需要大量時間跟精力關注市場
壓力跟情緒負擔頗大
真的喔
對啊 我們每天做我們都習慣了
是 已經沒有壓力大的問題了
這還好啦
就是不要嚇太大都不會壓力大
因為他都覺得心臟要超大顆
才有辦法做當從
對 我後來
我有去醫院檢查我心臟
花了兩萬多塊做最高級的健康檢查
他跟我說他沒看過一個心臟這麼好的
真的假的
完全沒概化
所以心臟真的滿大顆的
是每天在當場鍛鍊出來的
好長期要付超多的交易稅跟手續費
所以交易稅像我一年付四五千萬
那手續費也付很多
所以就可以參加很多券商的VIP晚會
像今年有看到陳真演唱會就這樣
好當中是一下單就虧損
為什麼這樣講
因為你一下單你就要負擔手續費交易稅
對
所以一下單事實上就虧損
所以你必須要戰勝手續費加交易稅
加到多少%才可以呢
一般來講大概
一般人是算千分之二
千分之二
一般人我們算手續費
你可以打個三折的話
算千分之二
那手續費沒有三折的
你不要來玩了啦
不要來玩了啦
你不要跟我說什麼五折六折玩當中
不要了啦
那個人家玩三折玩當沖都會玩到疲累
連五六折來玩
那我問一下如果我要玩當沖的話
我要先預期這檔個股
他要漲跌幅多少我才可以賺錢
預期漲跌幅多少
不要有這種預期
可是不是要扣掉這一些
對
為什麼說不要有這種預期
因為其實扣到這些
扣到這些就千分之二
所以至少漲跌就要千分之二
那為什麼說不要有預期
因為當你有預期的時候
你老是會卡在那邊
哎 千萬之我就是
幾個Tick嘛
對
我一個Tick能賺
好啦我一個Tick我都出
你這樣到後面的績效都很爛
因為
賺錢有分
大賺大賠小賺小賠
然後呢
你很在意那一兩個Tick
那麼你很容易遇到的就是
小賺
比方說我50塊買
我50.2就想賣
對你就在意
對
而且50.2萬
你賺一點點
然後分給券商跟政府
三分天下
你幹嘛
你幫兩個人打工幹嘛
對不對
所以當中我們最重要的
應該是怎麼樣
不是戰勝成本而已
我們當中最重要的是
我們要去找到大勝的機會
大家都很想要找到大勝的機會
對 找到大勝的機會就是說
你今天做完之後賺十幾%
那叫大勝
當中賺十幾%
我剛剛一開牌我們就給你看
昨天遇到一個跌停了嘛
碰到一個跌停了
那個就十幾趴啦
對 你要遇到
你要有機會賺到十幾趴當沖
那種當沖才過癮嘛
對不對 老是去賺
有的人去
之前還有一個人開課說
哇 我真的
我覺得市場上
不會做教育的不要出來開課好不好
不要這樣害人
我跟你講市場上有人出來教課
怎麼教你知道嗎
我第一堂當沖課
當沖我們先教各位
多少錢呢
我們先來算那個一個Tick賺幾%
例如說100塊
下一個Tick100.5嘛
是0.5%
那90塊下一個Tick是90.1
算起來大概0.1%
大概是這樣子
那所以呢
100塊的0.5%這個Tick比較大
所以呢
各位同學
我們找當沖的
一定要找一二開頭的
因為那個Tick比較大
真笑
裝笑
不然你去沖東華電信
都100開頭
你去沖它
你去沖
你看怎麼沖
沖不了
所以當沖重點不是那Tick
重點是它的波動
你要今天找一個
政府很大的股票去沖
才有意義
對不對
你看我剛剛給你看一個
今天波動十幾趴對不對你找高點賣掉低點回補你不是賺十幾%嗎你賺十幾%你的成本0.2%你看這賺你的成本佔那麼少你找一個100塊的股票
然後整天振幅0.5%
中華電信
對啊0.5%
你買要排隊賣要排隊
買了又不一定排得到賣
中股票連衝都不能衝
所以呢
我們要選對好的個股跟好的標的
所以其實我們今天就先把這個
從盤前我們到底要做什麼樣的準備
來選到好的標的
來做我們當中的選擇
對啊 所以盤前
盤前你就要想策略
你要想說我今天到底要幹嘛
要做哪些股票
那設定這個停損點
其實停損點我覺得最重要
停利還不一定
停利這個通常通常我們是
做多極拉出量停利
放空極殺出量停利
你要記得這個就好
那股票跟股期的正利價差
這個有時候你可以看得出來
他的股票的方向比較有機會往哪邊走
那通常假如是正價差就比較有機會往上
大概這樣這個是機會問題
但是我們不會為了正價差而去
而去做多股票
那雪谷的话
雪谷我有设计一个
当中标股神手的APP
那雪谷里面事实上是有两种
一个是资金关注焦点
那另外一个是大量换手高位
那资金关注焦点跟大量换手高位
他们两个都有一个特色
就是他们都有周转率在里面
那资金关注焦点就是
今天周转率突然拉高
然后比较偏多的股票
就很多人在進行交易了
對
那大量換手高位是
今天這個
周轉率拉高
但有很多格子聰的股
很多格子聰分點在裡面
所以我會從大量換手高位裡面
找機會來做空
資金關注焦點裡面
找機會來做多
所以第一個講到這個
資金關注焦點
表示很多人在關注這檔股票
所以第一個
其實我們這裡面找的周轉率
大概都是全國前20
可是你就記得
你今天做當初很簡單
你就
1700檔你都不用看了啦
你就看全國前20
周轉率排行榜
就好了
資金周轉率比較高的對你就做這20檔這20檔裡面又有分這20檔裡面就有分第一個前一天有漲停有漲停有很多隔日沖
然後現行沒有很強
那這個它有可能就大量換手高位
大量換手高位的白話文是什麼
就是隔日沖它會拉高出貨
拉高換散戶進來
所以大量換手
高度危險的股票
所以比較偏空
是
那假如今天周轉率突然拉上去了
嗯
然後呢昨天小紅小黑
那他是今天的資金關注焦點
大概這樣子
了解
我們多空大概會這樣選股啦
嗯哼
所以我們選完之後
接下來開盤了
9點了我們要做什麼事情
盤中你可以看一下
這個是籌碼K的資金流向可以看一下
那這個稍微看一下就可以了
因為你實際上關注的標的也實際不多
就是我們所講的
你就看全國前20
全國前20的周轉率就可以了
所以這是一個概念就是說
這資金可能是流到哪一個
比如說比方電子股比較多
或者說石化股比較多等等的
沒錯
所以除了這個資金之外
我們盤中還是要觀察一下股價的變化
而當中籌碼就是很重要的一個點
對 好
那這個盤中資金有了
第二個觀察買賣盤捷徑點
什麼叫捷徑點是什麼意思
買賣盤捷徑點
那我們先講一下
我們空股票要空在爆量漲不動
這個什麼時候會爆量
你去看那個江坡圖都有啦
股票急拉出很大量
然後你看到那個價格上不去
你要空在那個點
那買在爆量跌不動
急殺出量跌不大下去
就買在那個點
所以記得這兩個口訣
你記得這兩個口訣就對了
那股票急拉呢
它連次連量會亮紅燈
這裡
像這邊是亮綠燈
這個當外盤成交的話
它會亮紅燈
當燈熄滅的時候可能會買盤接近
爆量越大會越準
那股票急殺的時候
像這裡就急殺
急殺的時候連次連量亮綠燈
等到燈熄滅就準備做多的意思
所以我們就抓緊這兩個口訣
其實我們在我們的盤上面
其實都會看得到
整個資金的動態跟流向了對不對
沒錯
除了此之外我們在一些多圖的走勢也是要必須一起觀察的多圖走勢就是你必須要找到你今天做了這檔股票它的同族群的股票長怎樣同族群
比方說
像最近比較流行的是BVU
像之前比較流行的是軍工
是軍工類股的走勢
軍工類股的走勢
你看它走勢就有點像
所以就把比如說漢翔
欠富等等
就拉出來
然後把從一個產業的個股拉出來
看看它的圖是不是長得一樣
對 看它長得像不像
長得像 所以長得像是什麼意思
長得像
長得像你可以記得一點
ABCDE都長得很像
對
盤索子都很像
後來只有一個在拉
其他都沒在動
那代表這一段拉假的
拉假的是什麼意思
拉假就是這一段很有可能再回來
那個就是阻力它沒辦法同時發動
只能發動一支而已
那如果要玩當沖是要玩這種嗎
完當沖沒有
完當沖你都要先做好功課
當沖有分先買再賣
先賣再買的
你在前一天你就要想好
你今天要做哪一檔
那先買再賣的
你可以當天再看就可以
當天只要它的周轉率突然變高
那就有機會
所以分成兩種類型
那接著就是這個
盤中還有另外一個要觀察
我們剛剛講的捷徑
買盤捷徑是什麼意思
對你看這邊年次量
連次亮紅燈嘛
這就是個
這個連量連次也爆了連量也爆了
然後這邊都亮燈呢
就是等他滅了就是買盤結晶
那你可以簡單的說一下
連次跟連賣連量是什麼意思
連次哦這個這個是我設計的啦
因為
盤中的足比錯誤太快了
一般人看不懂啦
嗯那數太快了一直刷一直刷看不懂
所以呢我們是把它變慢
那變半怎麼變半呢
就是我每5秒算一次
5秒算一次
接這5秒內外盤獲勝內盤獲勝
總計起來
外盤獲勝一次
像這裡是外盤連續獲勝10次
那外盤的量加一加有200多張
那這兩個都報的代表說買盤捷徑
買完了大家買完了
那另外就是所謂的賣盤捷徑
你看這是殺下來
我們再看看那個價格
你要記得因為是同一檔
同一檔
你看這個價格買盤結晶是174.5
然後後面往下殺了變171
然後這邊變
負的20幾次然後200多
所以這個是那個賣盤捷徑
所以是一個是買完的
一個是賣完的訊號
我們都要注意了
一個是內盤訊號
了解
所以我們接下來是講一下
這一張圖
就是我們剛剛講的這一張
利基49681
這個我也立好了
這邊其實就是看到
我們剛剛的成交量跟這個價格
你看這個拉高買盤捷徑
我們這邊空了
所以你看它急拉買盤捷徑
你看這邊會有粗量
然後這邊會有一個pick
急轉彎
那我每天都會在我的IG
IG
可以後製一下
我在我的IG我都會貼我的點位圖
就是你那個點發生什麼事情
那個點就是
那個點像這綠色就是我今天空的點
這個很多投資人每天都在等這張圖
又看我今天做了哪一檔股票
然後他們說小哥你會不會太省
為什麼每次你弄完它就轉折下來
不是我太省
是因為那個點牌就是買盤接近點
我只不過是壓倒駱駝的最後一根稻草而已
抓好時間點
我抓好時間點
空空又掉下來
就這樣子
那一樣它殺下來
你看殺下來我們在這邊買
買一買之後它可能有個小盤彈
就這樣子
所以你主要的這個概念
其實就是參考那個時候的成交量
跟它的價格嘛對不對
沒錯
了解
所以這是我們盤中要做的事情了
那接下來一點半收盤之後
你會做一些檢討嗎
對會
第一個每天要做好交易盤型
第二個強勢股多單盡量報警
空單有賺
強勢股的空單有賺就跑
強勢股建議只短空一次
為什麼
因為強勢股就是很容易
因為後面這把你加上去
那弱勢股多單有賺就跑
就像搶板談嘛
搶板談有賺就跑
空單要盡量報警
那每天設定好最大虧損的金額
這二跟三其實它概念還滿接近
就是你不要一次覺得
我要賺多少我才走對不對
對啊
就是不要太貪心
可以這樣講嗎
應該這樣講說
你要分辨那盤股票到底是強勢還弱勢
就你就看前一天它長什麼樣
看它的籌碼
不能看價格那我講很強的你就記得你的空單不能擺太久不要跟市場對坐對每天設好最大虧損金額可動用之金額1%
假設你有100萬
可操作金額
你不能說100萬是你的救命錢
不行 那就不要玩了
100萬可動用金額
每天不能輸超過1萬
設定一個
你輸超過1萬
那心情壓力很大
你100萬一天輸10萬
那你怎麼活下去
只剩9天可以輸
那100萬輸1萬
那還好 反省一下
那務必掛好出價單
避免漲停空單流倉
那速度盤識別動作
速度盤是什麼意思
就是有時候突然急拉
速度很快 那時候先不要動
你先看清楚
空在股價漲不動
急拉會讓到軍線
是個找小賠的好機會
因為有時候我們做空的
就是空了之後還是往上拉
再回來碰到均線那個點
無論如何你都要先補掉
那你不要記得你的成本
反正你記得
誰記得成本誰痛苦
不要記得成本該出就要出
好
若持續賺錢的話
可以提升最大虧損金額
戶頭持續賺錢可以轉去自產
自產你是說
讓戶頭的潛水流動
這是什麼意思
就是要持續的保持資金的
對 你不是
我今天這個每天輸一萬
越來越厲害了
可以到每天輸十萬
每天輸百萬 每天輸千萬
也不要越玩越大
因為玩越大它的難度越高
那我問你
比方說我現在有一百萬的資金
然後我現在想要開始
介入當沖這個市場
你覺得我要投入多少比較好
投入多少
100萬都是你的
反正你要記得
你每天只能輸1萬
喔
那你每天當沖的金額
你有一百萬的話
你最好只沖100萬
但一般來講
一般你叫他說
沖100萬他還是覺得太少
太少嗎
我是覺得太多耶
你開始沖你這種
你就知道100萬不多
我太保守
100萬不多
因為
滑鼠隨便滑一下就100萬了
欸
100塊的你按個1
就10萬了
是啦 多兩個零
就買到台積電了對啊也有人台業在當沖的真的我也這道高價股比較少台積電有人在當沖而且它都是很厲害的大咖
才去沖台積電
他們沖台積電不是為了台積電
他們是為了台子齊
他可以在當沖台積電賠錢
但台子齊他要大賺
他是奮力把台積電往上拉
然後台子齊在那邊出貨
然後後面呢他只得把
他買了台積電把它賣下來
所以他當初台積電
你看他always賠錢
可是他事實上他可能在某個地方
一直在賺錢
所以你每次當沖的股票
都是電子股比較多嗎
如果都是強勢或流動
我當沖股票都是波動性大的股票
不一定是電子股
不一定
像今天就防疫股
對
它波動性大的股票每天不大一樣
反正我每天沖的股票
都是周轉運前十名的
所以你也不會去了解說這檔
他是做什麼的公司對不對
大概會知道
不會很詳細的去研究
因為那個流動太快了
我們的客人每天都在周轉
最近比較活潑的像BBU
最近比較常來的是BBU
了解 所以我們盤後檢討之外
其實還是要跟各位觀眾朋友講一題
就是今年如果你開始要做當床
到底要怎麼樣操作比較好
好 第一個持續觀察市場最近動態
比方說最近防疫
對 最近變防疫稍微起來
不過我覺得防疫那個
那個都是一時的而已
一時而已 那個不會太持久
第二個每天要做好籌碼研究功課
第三 研究盤面的主流股
那行情發動者最為有利
所以一般人沒辦法做
行情發動那個都是幾千萬
幾億身家人在做的
大多在做的
所以你真的要跟單速度要很快
那記得幾檔不要再追了
那多芳選股找主投買
上回效做多勝率比較大
那空芳選股我們就找高仰出貨股
高仰出貨股來做
或找一些有格日沖的
反正重點都是要有格日沖
因為格日沖它就是隔天會賣掉
對
有格日沖股票那些都是你的
這個跟你會比較
算是
算是你的夥伴
是不是就一起操作
你最後講一下
如果你的當沖心法到底有什麼你當沖這麼多年來第一個維持冷靜冷靜心跳大可對偶爾要跟自己對話一下最近跟對話是什麼跟自己講一下好加油不要慌
只是調整而已
早上大時代
大時代裡面的劇情
好就維持冷靜
不要太恐慌
其實不要恐慌一個很重要條件
就是你部位不要太大
你部位不大就不會恐慌
反正就下小一點
下小一點
那自營計畫每天給自己賠錢上線
多單遇到快跌停一律賣出
空單遇到快漲停一律回補
那第三個警惕風險
不要下超過自己可承受的範圍
那第四個預設停損單
第五個保持耐心
大單短進短出
因為風險啦
大單不要放太久
小單要贏到最後
偶爾需要大賺
大賺大賠小賺小賠
你記得不要出現大賠
偶爾要大賺
那麼你整體都會賺錢
你通常大賺會賺多少錢
大賺喔
我們
最近比較多的一次400多萬
那大賠
小賠啦小賠多少
小賠幾萬塊啊
到幾十萬就覺得是大賠了
就覺得賠的有點多
那你平均每天靠當沖可以賺多少錢
平均算不出來
最近12月好了
12月我貼一次對岸單
這個純當沖
純當沖是900多單月
但是實際上的帳單會比較醜
因為純當沖
當沖它是一個帳面上
會比較漂亮的一個狀況
因為你在虧損的時候
你有可能就不會當沖掉了
就流倉了
你有可能變隔日沖
所以我們常常當中間虧比較多
我們會流倉
然後隔天找小培出掉
所以你看到存當中的帳面會很漂亮
那當然再把隔天算起來
應該加退佣應該還是有五六百
一個月
做得順的話一個月常常是上百萬
所以今天真的是來跟我們交朋友
當然
好啦最後
好
好吃健康的生活
早睡早起
有人說他
那個
早上沒時間起來
12點起來可不可以
〔此段辨識失敗，約 30:00 起〕